David says it was his secret addiction
hidden from his family for nearly 15
years it ate away at him and his
finances in total he thinks he lost 35
000 pounds gambling but the emotional
cost was far greater I always thought
gamers are like a friend that wasn't a
friend like a dark shadow so when I was
gambling I felt like someone was with me
telling me to carry on doing and that
might sound a little bit weird but
that's how I was trying to think about
it but when you're in the midst of it
when you're in that the height of that
addiction is just completely not only
consumed it feels like you you've just
been squeezed and squeezed and squeezed
um you can't think of anything else but
doing that through counseling David
eventually broke that hold and in seven
and a half years bet free but while he
can now follow football and the World
Cup without wanting to gamble tens of
thousands can't and it's why the Royal
College of psychiatrists are warning the
tournament in Qatar could fuel
addictions this really acts as a trigger
I think following the games and so many
of them and so many more opportunities
to uh place bets Etc does act as a
trigger and increases
um anxiety and cravings and urges to
gamble online betting has made gambling
possible Anytime Anyplace it's only ever
a few clicks away with more than 400
gambling related suicides estimated in
England every year the calls for reform
have become deafening the government now
under more pressure than never to
deliver its long promised white paper I
just thought
they follow
people who are in a desperate need of
support and help and preventative
measures that is that's where the
government needs to be focusing their
attention campaigners are demanding a
statutory Levy for the industry and a
new independent regulator while the
government said it's finalizing details
of its review to ensure it's fit for the
digital age those who've experienced the
Dark Side of gambling say it can't come
soon enough either Bennett Sky News